We've been talking a lot about complex numbers together, but what if we have a
situation like this, where we have one complex number divided by another complex
number? Since right now, both the numerator and the denominator each have a real
and an imaginary component and one is not directly a factor of the other one, we
can't do anything with this expression. We often encounter fractions like this,
and usually, what we do to manipulate them differently is to change the
denominator in some way. What I'd like us to do then is to figure out how to
change the denominator of this fraction so that it ends up being the smallest
real number we can make it, other than 0, of course, since we don't want to
divide by 0. So, think critically about the past few quizzes we've done and what
you can multiply one complex number by to get a real number. Fill in whatever we
need to multiply at the top and bottom of this fraction by, to come up with an
equivalent fraction that has a real number in the denominator. I know this is
new and it probably feels a little bit difficult right now but just give it a
shot, and if you feel like you need to review a little bit to prepare for this
question, you can go back and what the past couple of videos.